There are a whole bunch of Trumpists and even
some non from Republicans who are getting
hugely bamboozled about the job market. And
as a result, the state of the economy. So
let's first talk about if you want to analyze
how an economy is doing. I've always said
you can't look at one thing. The stock market
is a popular thing to look at. If the stock
market's up, we've got a good economy. If
it's down, we've got a bad economy, but it's
only one piece. It only affects on average
the wealthier who disproportionately owned
shares of stock. So by itself it doesn't tell
us how the economy is doing at all. The unemployment
rate is another piece, but the one that's
widely published, which is called the U three
you don't have to understand too much about
this, but when we hear about, Oh, unemployment
is 3.7% that's what's called the [inaudible].
It falls very short of telling us everything
that we need to know.
Inflation and the consumer price index is
another element of how an economy is doing.
The strength of the dollar affects other aspects
of our economy, the quality of the jobs that
people have, wage growth versus wage contraction
or wage stagnation. And very often this becomes
completely politicized. And in the end, any
casual observer of politics and economics
loses what it actually is that is taking place.
You have Republicans saying Republican presidents
have great job markets and economies, democratic
presidents have bad ones. The opposite true
for Democrats. And what I've been trying to
do is to get past that. So for example, I
told you during the 2012 presidential campaign,
whether Obama wins reelection or whether Mitt
Romney wins, the economy will likely be pretty
good the next four years. Republican labor
force conspiracy theories were wrong under
Barack Obama, but their labor force bragging
under Trump is also wrong.
It's wrong on both sides of the equation as
the case may be. So the point today is that
one big piece that's missing from the great
job market that Donald Trump claims is the
quality of jobs. There is now a metric for
this, which is the Cornell CPA, U S private
sector job quality index. And the name isn't
so much important, but what it does is it
looks at the ratio of high wage, high hours
jobs to low wage, low hours jobs. There's
two ways that a job could be a low quality
job. It could be a low wage job or it could
be a low hours job. This index has steadily
fallen since 1990 for the last 30 years. Part
of this is because of the replacement of lots
of jobs that have been lost, making things
with service jobs. That includes restaurants
and many others. A whole bunch of the recent
job gains, not just under the Trump administration,
but under Obama as well, have been in retail,
leisure, hospitality.
That includes restaurants and other parts
of industry. Waste management is another area.
The sectors that have been growing pay a far
lower weekly income than this job. The manufacturing
jobs and other jobs that have been going away
either because they've been eliminated or
moved overseas. So the top line U three rate,
that unemployment rate that's often publicize
the one Trump brags about that's under 4%
is low. Donald Trump, of course, when it was
low under Obama, said the numbers were phony.
Now he brags about those numbers as evidence
of a great job market. But the more important
thing is that the quality of the jobs keeps
getting worse and because the income levels
of the high quality jobs keep going up while
low quality jobs don't, this is furthering
inequality. The gap is growing even more in
the United States. Now it's important to also
note very often the argument is made that
when you have a low U three unemployment rate,
you have a lot of people working two jobs
and that's a sign that that actually the economy
is weak.
This is very often a red herring and it's
a red herring here. If you actually look at
the number of people working two jobs right
now, it's quite low historically. So I, I
don't, you know, I, I know that that's a talking
point I could use if I merely wanted to play
partisan politics. That's not what I'm here
to do. I'm actually to tell you what the truth
is in the real world. The right loves using
that talking point, let's not use it. Okay?
We don't need to. This is where we come back
to our strategy from the left, from the side
that wants the socially democratic reforms.
We can't pretend that a pretty good economy
isn't pretty good by the standards that are
used to measure economies. The economy is
pretty good right now. A lot of it has nothing
to do with Donald Trump whatsoever, but let's
focus on the things that aren't going well.
People are working jobs that they hate to
keep healthcare. That's terrible. Okay. Wage
stagnation, really bad inequality, terrible
and furthered by what we're talking about
here are the replacement of quality jobs with
low quality jobs. Um, lack of democratic workplaces.
We've talked about the democratization of
the workplace. That's a problem. Stock market
to the extent that it benefits some people,
it's riding high. It's not going to last forever.
It never does. We lose credibility when we
attack them in the factually indefensible
ways that they attack us. But we don't need
to do that because there is plenty of bad
to go around and that's where we should be
focusing our energies and to be, to be perfectly
Frank, it favors the policies we're advocating
for separating healthcare from employment,
democratizing the workplace, dealing with
inequality, whether it's with a higher progressive
marginal tax rate, taxing capital gains at
ordinary income.
We have all the different tools in our, at
our disposal, all of the problems that are
really the problems now point to the reforms
we want to make. So let's not maybe miss the
forest for the trees is not the right metaphor
here, but let's not do what they do when we
don't need to do it. From a moral perspective,
let's not stoop to their level, but it also
doesn't benefit us because focusing on the
real problems points to the solutions being
the suggestions we've been making social Democrats
have been making for
a very long time.